de quel coin de la planète venez-vous
oui pourquoi pas non
qui n'est pas une autre question je
disais de quel coin de la planète
pourquoi pas donc c'est pas la bonne
planète
[Rires]
a proposé un live au McDo des
Champs-Élysées hier soir en fait là où
il est installé là vous le voyez il est
au niveau des caisses du McDonald's
alors il y avait que des invités et le
personnel du McDo et on a vu ça sur les
réseaux sociaux abondamment je voulais
vous parler des tonnes qui est gérant
d'une discothèque à long à Lens pardon
qui s'appelle le club et en fait il a
décidé de faire bénir sa discothèque dès
l'ouverture pour ne pas qu'il y ait de
mauvaises ondes donc il a fait venir un
prêtre il est arrivé à 11h du matin avec
son petit vélo il a commencé à prononcer
donc des prières et à mettre de nos
bénites partout dans les coins sur un
fond de pop louange je vous fais écouter
un petit peu ce que c'est la pop
française
[Musique]
à la une de ce 28 juin la suite est fin
de notre feuilleton de la semaine et BFM
Marseille qui n'est quand même pas super
cool avec le président de la République
ou alors il manque juste une pause dans
la phrase
le Vieux-Port Emmanuel Macron peut nous
y trouver à 10 offres d'emploi non bravo
pas si vieux bravo
[Rires]
du Père du Fils du Saint-Esprit Emmanuel
Macron fait donc part de son émotion 24
heures après la mort de Naël un jeune
homme de 17 ans tué par un policier
après un refus d'obtempérer en visite à
Marseille le chef de l'État exprime sa
solidarité avec la famille écoutez
nous avons un adolescent qui qui a été
tué cette inexplicable inexcusable et
d'abord je ce sont des mots d'affection
de peine partagée et de soutien à sa
famille et à ses proches à notaire ce
sont des fusées d'artifices qui ont été
tirés à proximité de la préfecture là où
a eu lieu le drame d'hier un incendie
c'est par ailleurs déclaré dans une
école de musique incendie pour lequel
les pompiers on sera rapidement
intervenus des feux ont été allumés le
long des rails du rera entre Nanterre et
Rueil-Malmaison plusieurs voitures des
poubelles des abribus ont été détruits
endommagés des manifestants également de
dresser quelques barricades au réveil
les habitants découvrent les stigmates
d'une nuit de guérilla urbaine
comme cette dame qui vit dans le
quartier depuis 53 ans
je me suis couché à minuit à 2h j'ai
entendu une cavalcade de des jeunes qui
étaient coursés par les policiers et
après ça s'est arrêté rien ne pourra
remplacer une vie humaine donc voilà une
voiture qui crame ou deux voitures qui
crame de ça et là moi personnellement ça
me fait moins mal que
que la perte en vue humaine quoi
j'observe que ceux qui réclament un
délai de dessin quand une grand-mère et
sa petite fille sont agressés à Bordeaux
et dénoncent la récupération politique
j'observe que les mêmes étaient les
premiers hier soir à condamner la police
a oublié la présomption d'innocence et à
faire fi de l'enquête qui commence
Clémentine Notin député de la France
insoumise à parler d'une exécution
sommaire c'est son droit la question
est-ce qu'il y aura des oui il y aura
des émeutes pourquoi parce qu'il y a un
parti politique qui appelle à l'émeute
il y a aujourd'hui une force pour un
mouvement politique français qui est en
train de dire la police tu donc
rebellez-vous contre l'autorité
policière là ça va là il va y avoir des
choses très graves puisque des
représentants du peuple sont en train de
légitimer la violence pour ne pas dire
en train de l'appeler la violence là
nous avons franchi un seuil qui est le
préambule de la guerre civile de toute
façon il y a une partie de la gauche qui
rêve d'un George Floyd de la française
pour faire le procès et instruire le
procès d'une police qui serait
intrinsèquement raciste parce que c'est
ça d'ailleurs le sujet c'est que la
police serait raciste bien sûr on
arrêtera et qu'elle n'aurait pas tiré si
c'était une personne blanche bien sûr il
était au volant c'est ça le discours qui
est relié et qui demande de policiers
que fait la police et quand la police
intervient malheureusement il peut aussi
y avoir des bavures et on est toujours
coincé entre les deux Chris ces deux
extrêmes Christophe on va écouter Mehdi
qui nous appelle des Hauts-de-Seine
bonjour Mehdi bonjour bonjour
la vérité on va dire ce qui se passe si
c'est pas un maghrébin il est vivant
vous avez compris ce que je vous dis là
les policiers peuvent tirer sur une
personne susceptible de perpétrer des
atteintes dans sa fuite la loi prévoit
le terme susceptible ce qui est source
d'un pouvoir discrétionnaire extrêmement
important dans la manière dont les
fonctionnaires vont pouvoir estimer
qu'il y a
ou non une un danger pour eux-mêmes ou
pour autrui et c'est bien en raison de
ce risque d'arbitraire que on voit
aujourd'hui une recrudescence des
personnes qui décèdent en arrière vous
remontez en arrière tous les refus
d'obtempérer ce sont soit des mamadous
soit démocars d'accord rechercher
chercher allez-y
moi je peux pas l'entendre je suis
désolé Mehdi Mehdi Mehdi on a des sons
ce qui a été dit par contre Mehdi
j'aimerais juste compléter mon propos on
vous a écouté moi je peux pas laisser
passer le côté propos racisme il n'a pas
eu de propos racistes je dis que cet
incident ce serait pas produit dans
d'autres pays parce que un
automobiliste interpellé par la police
pointée il bouge pas alors je sais pas
pourquoi en France bah il s'en foutent
[Musique]
je suis à l'arrêt j'ai comme une faute
grave j'ai un policier qui me pointe une
arme ce qui est déjà pas très bien
peut-être mais je bouge pas je bouge pas
en fait j'ai peur j'ai peur non mais je
dors parce que j'ai peur mais parce que
j'ai peur je bouge pas
c'est que c'est que les flics abattent
des Maghrébins sans aucune raison c'est
ça que vous dites
trouvez moi le concert sur un refus
d'obtempérer ces 10 dernières années
trouvez-moi un Pascal on est passé de
1000 à 27000 tout à fait et ce qu'on
fait avec 22 25 822 mais en fait les
policiers aujourd'hui moi je suis
policier je suis à dans la BAC comme
vous dites à 2h du matin mais je veux
j'interviens plus mais vous savez je dis
je vais pas y aller il y a trop de
danger je viens d'un ressenti d'abord je
peux tuer quelqu'un effectivement et
c'est je n'ai pas envie d'être seul
s'était arrêté le flic l'aurait quand
même fumé parce que c'était
vous pouvez pas dire ça c'est
un procès vous faites vous dites et puis
en disant ça vous mettez 1000 points
dans la balance du rassemblement
national franchement c'est la prochaine
attention au milieu de la nuit la mère
de Naël qui appelle à une marche blanche
demain dit son chagrin sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'était ma vie c'était mon meilleur ami
c'était mon fils c'était ma c'était tout
pour moi on était complice comme pas
possible
ce matin il m'a fait un gros bisou il
m'a dit maman je t'aime je me dis pas
attention à toi je t'aime fais attention
à toi voilà